oh wait we're doing in heaven thank you
I thought you were taking a picture I
forget you no cameras now they're
pictures or video they're everything
no no there's no time limit at all you
know if you're called to be any type of
an artist but especially you know an
actor or singer or something like that
you know I've had friends of mine that
have come they've been disillusioned and
they quit and actors don't put they you
know to me an actor will act if it's in
a play that that pays nothing they'll do
dinner theater he'll do whatever and
just keep keep working because it's the
work that they love not necessarily the
level of fame or success you know and
one of the things that I'm proudest of
is an actor is light I did i did i did
children of a lesser God and you know it
was a Broadway yeah Broadway serie a
series out at Riverside that was
Riverside San Bernardino theater VRS
California theatre the arts and ran for
two weeks and no you can't film plays
and that was the most rewarding
experience for me because I'm sitting
there doing this role that I'm really
really proud of and then all of a sudden
at the end you got 4,000 people on there
on their feet
you know clapping for me and I was like
I love it I love that I could affect
people that way and it's really
gratifying so no there's no time limit
you got to remember like folks like jeez
now whenever I start a sentence like
that the name goes out of my head
oh boy I'm not gonna remember his name
but there are there actors and actresses
that you know they start being noticed
in their 50s and 60s you know Wilford
Brimley okay his birth all of a sudden
he came out in China Syndrome and that
was his first aid well he was well into
his fifties but that wasn't an overnight
success I guarantee you he was working
before that just nobody saw and so no
there's no time limit at all at all no
problem yeah yeah well people think that
that if you if you attain a certain
level of success that may have like a
magic contact you know you can pick up
the phone he's gonna take right you know
it's you know it's it's tough enough to
fight for an actor to get himself in
something you know and it's like the
last person that can help an actor
unless they're already working on it is
another actor if they're working on
something I can I can give a shout out
to the casting director if I have a good
relationship with them and say listen
there's this character in this movie and
and it's only a line or two but you know
do you mind you know do you think my
friend is right for it but very very
that doesn't happen very often
I mean obviously the more well-known you
are in the morning more help you can
divvy out but at that point everybody's
got their hand up going so it really is
just just do the best you can to get
yourself out there and just keep working
just keep working and dump you know
ignore and until until a very very
powerful agent you know is rapping you
don't worry about hey just do what you
love yeah
you